you
happy weekend everybody's we got some
new Game of Thrones footage let's break
it down doesn't it just make you
salivate for more footage they're coming
to South by Southwest in the next month
next couple of weeks really so the idea
is is they might be dropping something
new because they've been dropping all
these little teasers this is mostly
hyping up Oathkeeper which is still in
Brienne's position the idea that keeping
her oath the tenants of chivalry are so
important to her all she's wanted her
whole life is to be of service as a
knight to a lord or lady and now she's
in service to Sauza
so her OSes to her but the big twist is
the past couple seasons is that her
heart has been pulling her to Jaime
which has come into conflict with her
oath there's so much going on right now
so I'll say there is a new round of the
game of Thrones giveaway going on I'm
giving away enhanced editions of the
book all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so the whole Jaime Brienne
Oathkeeper think came to a head last
season when the Lannisters were trying
to take Riverrun but Brienne had come to
petition the blackfish to get men to
help Sansa and Jon fight the forces of
the Bolton's in the Battle of Winterfell
so there's this really amazing moment
where Brienne goes to talk to Jamie and
they're sort of it ODS now they're on
opposite sides of the conflict and then
you have Bronn acting the comedian with
Podrick just completely cutting the
tension it was a perfect scene because
you have these two characters that
haven't seen each other for a while the
last time they've seen each other was
during season 4 when she got her new
armor Jaime gave her the sword in the
mission by Lady Sansa
protect her returned her to her family
looks like a siege milady you have a
keen military Minds pod I thought you'd
be dead by now not yet really over why
she looks at him well when I look at an
extremely irritated Sheik multi box your
nights at Amy I know there is on you I'm
seeing it like I'm a Lannister mask
betray my own house
you gave it to me for a purpose I've
achieved a purpose
yawns he'll always be used so that is
why Brienne tried to give him back oh
keeper when she met him again because
she said her mission was successful I
was able to find her I'm protecting her
now but it's so beautiful the way they
cut the dialogue they're just no words
are just kind of looking at each other
both acknowledging the tension in the
room and the reality of the situation
and what it is they're there to do Jamie
is there to take down the blackfish
Brienne needs him very much
always the realist Brienne tells them
that if they were to meet on the field
of battle that next day that she's going
to have to throw down and she is a
badass there's no way that Jamie could
beat her in a fight maybe if he had both
of his hands still but he sort of Nod
acknowledges that but probably isn't too
worried in that moment because he has
the Lannister army at his back so even
if he goes down a little bit there's no
way she'd be able to get away scot-free
but obviously that's not the way things
went down so it sounds like
circumstances might bring them back
together again and we're all hoping for
some sort of Jamie redemption even if he
never achieves Redemption more
redemptive moments like this where he
saves Brienne from the bear then gives
her the sword back just as a sign of his
affection and how much he respects her
as a person like you are such a better
person than I am I am human trash you
are the ideal that I aspire to be so the
big hope of season seven is that more
Brienne rubs off on Jaime but it seems
like they're prolonging that quite a bit
because now he's still at the head of
the Lannister army we're gearing for
another version of the war of the five
kings so let me know in the comments how
long do you think it's going to take
it's a like the 7 to 8 episode run that
we're going to get for Jaime to turn
against his family if he ever does do
you think that he would ever turn
against the Lannisters under any
circumstance I know there's the theory
of the Queen Slayer the valonqar I'll
add a link to that the end of this
because it's a fascinating theory that
Jaime will be the one to eventually kill
Cersei but it's still a theory at this
point because the show's gone so far off
book but really I think the other side
of the seas are in a more general way
it's just them saying that everyone is
gearing up for war because the
Oathkeeper blade is being sharpened on a
whetstone like you can hear it grinding
in the background but the thing is
Valyrian steel actually doesn't need to
be
sharpen that much so it's really just a
props Department sharpening it just a
little bit let me know what do you think
about this teaser what do you think it
implies and when do you think we're
actually going to get some new footage
remember South by Southwest is happening
in the next couple weeks sophie turner
amazing Williams Dan and Dave are both
going to do a special HBO panel so there
is a high likelihood that there will be
some kind of trailer some kind of
footage shown off and they will probably
post that online so of course I'll do a
video for whatever they end up doing
even if there isn't a real trailer I'll
still do a video for whatever
information does they reveal because now
we're in that corridor where they're
finishing up filming and they actually
have stuff to talk about so these are
kind of like those non trailer teasers
from last year where they didn't have
really new footage but they were teasing
new concepts like brand and the
three-eyed Raven so it's all really cool
it'll be interesting to see how they
market this show without actually having
a trailer ready like hey we're working
on it this is so amazing like they're
trying to hype up the idea to so much
work as going into season seven because
there are fewer episodes and they're
spending a lot more money and time
what's going to happen next is I have
more Logan videos to post Easter eggs
the future of those characters so
there's a whole bunch of comic book
stuff happening this weekend let me know
what you want me to do for my next game
of Thrones bonus video in the comments
below I'll say congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Brian gates
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video I'll just
announce the winner when I post that
next Game of Thrones video while you
wait for that you can click here to
rewatch that Deadpool trailer and you
can click here for all my other Game of
Thrones videos thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys in the next video
you